in other videos we talk about the rapid
spread of islam and one of the
interesting things about these early
islamic empires is they preserved much
of what they inherited from the
byzantine and the persian empires the
infrastructure including the roads the
bureaucracy a lot of the culture and
they also began to collect the knowledge
from within the empire and from the
peoples that they encountered on the
borders of the empire including the
indians and the chinese and they did
this throughout the umayyad dynasty but
it really came to its full fruition
during the abbasid caliphate
now the abbasid caliphate one of the
first things they did under the caliph
al-mansour is build baghdad and move the
capital of the empire to baghdad
now one of al-mansour's successors
al-rasheed is famous for making baghdad
a center of learning according to the
historian will john william draper this
is a a sense of what life was like under
al-rashid's rule during the period of
the khalas the learned men of the
christians and the jews were not only
held in great esteem but were appointed
to posts of great responsibility and
were promoted to the high-ranking jobs
in the government he calif haroon
rasheed never considered to which
country a learned person belonged nor
his faith and belief but only his
excellence in the field of learning and
to get a sense of how much learning and
how advanced the knowledge began to be
especially under the the in the
rulership of al-rashid during this time
he was a contemporary of charlemagne who
was the frankish king he was also the
first holy roman
emperor
and so it's this region right over here
and they were trading gifts and
and this is a historical account
harun al-rasheed sends charlemagne this
water clock and it's so foreign to the
franks to charlemagne that he thinks
that it's it must be some type of of
magic that it can't be explained by just
normal means
and then things really get
invested in in terms of collecting
knowledge as we get into the rule of
al-rashid's son
al-mammoon where he creates in baghdad
what is called the house of wisdom which
is this center of learning of
mathematics astronomy physics medicine
geography and map making poetry
philosophy and over the next several
hundred years these abbasid khalifs are
going to sponsor scholars from india
learn it in sanskrit and the sans
ancient sanskrit texts in greek chinese
persian to translate as much of that
knowledge and to collect it in libraries
in cities like baghdad to translate into
arabic and to collect all of that
knowledge in one place
and just to get a sense of the type of
advances that occurred
during this golden age of islam which
correlates strongly or is essentially
during the abbasid dynasty and it ends
with the mongol invasion in the middle
of the 13th century right over here
there are
scientists like al-khwarzami
and al-korzami is a persian
mathematician and physicist
and he's famous for being the the father
of algebra the word algebra that we now
have today and one the subject you can
learn a lot about on khan academy it
comes from the arabic word al-jabbar and
his book
which literally means and those of you
who might speak arabic or persian or
even hindi urdu might recognize ketab as
book and then hisab is calculation and
algebra is an operation of completion
and it's essentially this
it's one of the operations we now do in
algebra where you're doing the same
thing to both sides of the equation and
balancing it was also a very similar a
similar operation
he also brought
the indian number system or the hindu
numerals he brought them to the islamic
empire and that was really the bridge to
bringing it to the west famously pope
sylvester ii
he was educated in catalonia with the
point of acquiring knowledge that was
gained from the arabs remember the arabs
were in control or the islamic empires
it was not the abbasids it was actually
the remnants of the umayyads were in
control of spain at the time
but because of that this area was
considered a center of learning and pope
sylvester who got his education there
he's the one that is often given credit
for being one of the first to introduce
the decimal numeral system this hindu
arabic decimal system that we now use
for our numeric system as opposed to
something like roman numerals another
very interesting thing is not only the
word algebra comes from algebra
but the word algorithm is literally
comes from his name the name
is me al-khwarizmi in latin they
pronounce his algorithmi
so other significant
contributors to
the science of all of human civilization
are people like
al-marwazi al-marwazi once again in
baghdad
and he would have been a contemporary of
al-quarizmi
and he if you've ever taken trigonometry
or if you're about to take trigonometry
he is accredited with coming up with the
core trigonometric functions we're
talking about sine cosine
tangent and cotangent it might have been
marwazi or it might have been another
mathematician named al buzzani who came
a little bit after or a lot depending on
a human scale but was also based in
baghdad
and together they came up with the six
the six trigonometric functions they
weren't contemporaries of each other but
they both made significant contributions
to what we now call trigonometry
including many of the trigonometric
identities that we now learn in high
school
now you also
have
physicists mathematicians astronomers
like
al
and he is credited as getting one of the
more sophisticated views of how light
and vision works these are some quotes
from al hazen from each point of every
colored body illuminated by any light
issue light and color along every
straight line that can be drawn from
that point this is a fairly
sophisticated view of how light actually
works and he's also credited with with
using and understanding the scientific
method several hundred years before the
renaissance in europe
the duty of a man the duty of the man
who investigates the writing of
scientists if learning the truth is his
goal is to make himself an enemy of all
that he reads and attack it from every
side he should also suspect himself as
he performs his critical examination of
it
so that he may avoid falling into either
prejudice or
leniency
and now another very famous poet
philosopher mathematician polymath of
the time was omar khayyam and in the
west he is most famous for his poetry
most famously the work of the rabbiath
the translation by fitzgerald but he was
also a significant philosopher
mathematician this is a picture of some
of his work right over here you can see
that he did his work in the 11th and the
12th centuries and he did it from
bukhara but he investigated
pascal's triangle and the binomial
theorem and keep in mind this was over
500 years before pascal so maybe it
should actually be called kyam's
triangle and just to get a sense of his
poetry or a sense of the rebuyeth in
general which i encourage you to look up
and read and this is at least
fitzgerald's
translation of it
and that inverted bowl we call the sky
where under crawling cooped we live and
die lift not thy hands to it for help
for it rolled impotently on as thou or i
so as you can imagine this the islamic
world these empires between
the eighth and 13th centuries it was
actually a very powerful bridge of human
knowledge taking knowledge from the
indians the chinese the ancient greeks
and providing a bridge
during the dark ages in europe and get a
sense of that we have some texts from
some historians on that time period this
is some text from
this is some text from the historian
philip hidy
and he wrote during all the first part
of the middle ages no other people made
as important a contribution to human
progress as did the arabs if we take
this term to mean all those whose mother
tongue was arabic and not merely those
living in the arabian peninsula for
centuries arabic was the language of
learning culture and intellectual
progress for the whole of the civilized
world with the exception of the far east
from the 9th to the 12th century there
were more philosophical medical
historical religious astronomical and
geographical works written in arabic
than in any other human tongue
and we also have a frame a point of view
from
bertrand russell in his history of
western philosophy who wrote
our use of the phrase the dark ages to
cover the period from 699 to 1000 marks
our undue concentration on western
europe
in china this period includes the time
of the tang dynasty the greatest age of
chinese poetry
from india to spain the brilliant
civilization of islam flourished what
was lost to christendom at this time was
not lost to civilization but quite the
contrary
to us it seems that western european
civilization is civilization
but this is a narrow view